God knows I've asked the media every
damn chance I can so today I'm going to
do the opposite here goes after the El
Paso shooting a striking statistic
appeared at 226 percent jump in hate
crimes that were linked to Trump rallies
based on a study that had yet to be
peer-reviewed and it went everywhere
thankfully everywhere included the great
Reason magazine who independently
analyzed the thing but then they also
analyzed the effect of Hillary Clinton's
campaign rallies using the same
framework they found that her rallies
led to an even greater increase in hate
crimes than Trump rallies right their
reason just exposed what happens when
junk science marries the media it
creates really stupid offspring the
study it compared counties with rallies
to others without them
now political rallies are usually held
near large populations where raw crime
numbers are higher so no surprise big
cities where rallies took place also had
a few incidents of hate crimes
unlike smaller towns without rallies who
reported no such crimes so quite easily
reasons showed that you could do the
same with iller rallies that the study
authors did with Trump's how could the
media fall for this well they wanted to
fall for it
it's how you got Cavanaugh Covington
smollett they sell the junk to people
who need to believe the same thing they
believe maybe they should report that
crime since that business model seems
closer to a felony than it does to
journalism you know Dana I hate Reason
magazine because well I applied for a
job there in 1989 or 1990 and I didn't
get it who was the culprit well the
editor was Victoria postural okay I
think so I blame her but then reason
became but recent does stories like this
almost weekly for the past 50 years I
bet that they are gonna do one on
California emissions and how it was they
do do boring stories that's true no I'm
saying that they would explain it to
people so that they don't go around
saying oh wow they do take fornia is so
much bigger than everyone out there
doing yeoman's work it's at a word
vaping they're doing yeoman's work on
vaping they always take the other side
that people aren't reporting on and in
this case they found but you know
detectable impact Jessie from the
rallies it found a larger impact from
Hillary's just the show was all junk I'm
so glad you're doing this story this is
a very important story yeah I usually
don't say that about your monologues but
this time I will make an exception
your takeaway as mr. Gutfeld was is that
professors aren't really that smart hold
them in this big high esteem and yes
some of them are doing groundbreaking
work yes some of them are brilliant but
a lot of those excuse me I think your
sisters on the phone okay she's an
exception also in this case they're not
even that book smart okay so let's just
like check ourselves they indoctrinate
our children and push a lot of fake news
but also look how easy it is for fake
news to go mainstream you take a
professor
The Washington Post gave them an
opportunity to write this under the hard
news banner as a legit article and then
everybody reads it and then it gets on
cable TV and then politicians start
talking about it very very slick also
extrapolate this out for a second how
many junk science studies have they done
on global warming on guns yep on Russia
think about all the other fake things
that have gotten mainstream but if the
simple fact check proves the wrong and
then lastly conservative media is
basically saving this country they're
doing God's work they are fact-checking
the New York Times CNN they're
constantly poking holes it's exhausting
yeah and I think 75% of conservative
media all they're doing is rebutting the
lies told by Democrats and the
mainstream I put what I got to point out
and you reason is not a conservative
magazine it's it's libertarian and they
they they hold Trump's feet to the fire
more than anybody but they also are so
good at at reading that they read the
stuff that the other journalists don't
let me notice they read the footnotes
well I'm all for them I like that kind
of journalism I think you debunk myths
and yeah that's very important but I
mean what I'm listening to Jesse and I'm
thinking wow I think Jesse sees this as
somehow affirming his perspective not
debunking anything I mean the reality is
just this was bunked with that study was
but it didn't debunk the idea that hate
crime really has spiked
in the country like I think it says here
in my notes FBI yes flee 2016 or 2017
seventeen percent jump in hate crimes 37
percent jump in attacks on Jewish people
new blame Trump is not coming from from
a criminal justice background with the
most disturbing thing to me about this
about the original story that was put
forth is the fact that public perception
matters it matters for law enforcement
in matters of safety it matters for the
victims that had a real effect and the
sad part to me is that were the only
ones kind of putting forth the
correction the other the other way were
the mothering watch heard of that study
I heard of the box covered it the
Washington Post covered it I just never
heard it was retweeted by presidential
candidates yes yeah but anyway it's you
know that's why I read reason even
though they rejected me oh I will never
forget that but that ended I ended up
here if I have been working at reason I
wouldn't be here you'd be reading
footnotes I'd be reading footnotes